flat
mountain
i've been so excited about
the simultaneity
being able to be packaged into an
artistic
distillation of the nature of reality
and it's so beautiful how
the flatness is so
deeply resonant with the non-dual
meanwhile the mountain is so
resonant with the
path to enlightenment
the diamond necklace that is already
around
each of our necks yet it remains for us
to
recognize it
and that's why it's called the veilless
veil
that's why it's called the gateless gate
the flat mountain the bubbleless
bubble the pathless path
as adi shankara
says i am in my village
yet i need a path to get to my village
as fred davis said on our show
recently i'm in the chair in my office
but can you show me the path to the
chair in my office
you have the diamond necklace around
your neck
yet we're seeking externally
for what is already present
right here and so
that's why the sufi metaphysic says
only those who are truly ignorant seek
what is already there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
and it's beautiful because it both
encompasses the non-dual
the flatness while it also encompasses
the dual
the seeking the enlightenment the
recognition
of as rumi said the diamond
necklace already around our neck
and there's a lot more nuance to it as
well with true simultaneity especially
in the sense of what the quote
individual has become
in modernity because the last couple
hundred years and especially the last
couple of decades
have shown us that each one of the
diamonds
each jewel around our necks
is refracting the source light
in a unique artistic expression
and because of that we must also
simultaneously adore
the unique individuation while we
also simultaneously recognize the
ultimate as the non-dual
and that's why when you look at the eye
of each human you see the pupil
itself is the non-dual the eternal
the infinite the awareness
that is shared meanwhile
the iris the unique
coloration for each individual
is the beautiful artistic
expression of the infinite
of our source into
this dreamed creation design
and that's why the
infinite amount of modulations
or fluctuations of energy
from a perspective of quantum mechanics
give the appearance
of form give the appearance of
matter similarly
the infinite amount of modulations or
fluctuations of
music they give
the
infinite combinations of songs
that can be played similarly with an
artistic palette of colors
all of the different combinators and
permutations
of those color combinations that exist
and
this creation design being one
of those color combinators being one
of those songs musically
being one of those energetic
appearances quantum mechanically
all of these codes are very explained
like i'm five all of these
maps are very childlike the analogies
are very first principled and they're
very
friendly for children because
the codes are right under our nose the
maps are right under our nose
the simplicity is critical
and for those that also
haven't seen the flat mountain visual
this is it and we will be referencing it
here
throughout
all right let's jump into the
flat ness in the true simultaneity
so again the true simultaneity can be
thought of
as the ultimate non-duality
the ultimate infinity the ultimate
ineffable
the ultimate absolute
that is eternal
and then the next
layer simultaneously
is the dualistic concession
which we will get to here in a bit
of there being something to seek of
there being
enlightenment of their being well-being
versus suffering
and of entrepreneurially and creatively
architecting the social fabric to become
more prosperous and more abundant and
tackle our biggest challenges
and maximize human potential in this
dreamed creation
and then simultaneously there's one more
layer
and that layer is of the individual of
the multiplicity
and that is the pupil that is the iris
around the pupil
that is the unique creative expression
of each of us of infinity of source
and to be able to hold these
simultaneously
is the nature of reality
to be able to navigate them flawlessly
and frictionlessly and gracefully and
wisely and tailor
every single conversation to these
layers that you have
is it
so the flat is
the non-dual the ineffable the absolute
the ultimate
this is what tatvam asi means
which means you are that i am
that we are that just like
john 10 30 says i and my father are
one again these are perennial wisdoms
across the planet that we are it
we are god we are that we are the
ultimate we are the
ineffable we are that expressing itself
eternally
and this is just one expression this
dreamed creation design is
one expression and therefore there's
nothing to seek
you're already it
and there's this always already present
this very is-ness it's very subtle
but just the very is-ness of this
dreamed creation
of life that very is-ness
is already perfection that is already
the ineffable that is the absolute
it's eternal it's gorgeous it's
fireworks that are endless and that just
make you want to drop your jaw and just
be in awe
at the creativity and the art and the
play
and this is also the flatness of the
paper
so the very fact that the image
itself is flat the paper is flat
that's that non-dual component to it
there will be another one that we'll
discuss in a bit
around that as well therefore there's
also no ego death
there's no divine rebirth all
is simply story
that it's simply
myth that it's
simply awareness
colorfully explaining
the fireworks that it's experiencing
and it's cool for awareness to
explain the fireworks that it's
experiencing
but is it possible for awareness which
is an
agent of the infinite of the absolute
is it possible for that awareness to be
able to create a
detailed symbolic
explanation of itself
of the absolute of the ineffable of the
ultimate
and that's why the law of one and many
of the other
traditions say
be the wind why try
and capture the wind and put it into a
book
my
reaction to that is that this expression
of the infinite is simply
intuitively channeling the artistic
expression which is to
look at itself
and want to put the wind
artistically into a book and into
interviews and into animated series and
anthologies
and into enlightenment media
and therefore you don't have to become
buddha
christ ramana maharshi
you are already the awakened one
and this is where the
synthesis with modernity is so
fascinating
especially with science and technology
and engineering
because the same way that we're
decentralizing
everything right now we're turning
everything into a heterarchy
is very much like the non-dual tradition
it's fascinating it's like the
mycelial networks underground as well
because they are very much like the
decentralized
non-dual neurological neural network
of nature of evolution
of the dreamed creation design that this
is
and then to sort of juxtapose that
with
the mountain
and the mountain is very much like
centralized and very much hierarchical
and simultaneity would say that yes it's
important to both have decentralization
and also to have centralization why
well in the sense of simultaneity
when you undergo a
broken bone you want to know
hierarchically who is the best surgeon
around for you to get your broken bone
fixed
quite simple you can even boil it down
to i would like a watermelon and it's
like
who's the best local farmer for
watermelons
that's going to be a reoccurring theme
forever is synthesis
distillation simultaneity
how many of the layers can you hold
simultaneously
once you learn how to hold all of the
layers simultaneously you win
once you learn how to navigate those
like a jedi
and tailor it to each and every single
experience that you have you win
so the mountain's the dualistic
concession this means that they're
seeking there's finding there's
enlightenment
there's vidya and avidya so there's
knowledge and there's ignorance
there's remembering and there's
forgetting
there's the gps callback which is like
the parable of the prodigal son
so in the parable of the prodigal son in
the abrahamic tradition
the sun goes out and out and out
and hits a breaking point
and then he turns back inward
back to his family back to
the awareness consciousness itself
as an analogy as a metaphor
and going all the way to that god
realization to the realization of the
absolute
of the ineffable of the ultimate
and in doing so
enables wu way enables effortless action
enables the channeling of the highest
morality
into the social fabric in the tantric
path
of weaving the enlightened realizations
so there's no more
egoic separate contracted finite entity
that's going
and self-dealing and greedy and
scared and fear-driven anxiety-driven
that has dissolved like a sugar cube in
the hot tea of infinity
and now it's a natural process as the
creative expression
going outward harmonically with the
planetary ecology
with understanding the other as the self
as the one and just being a unique
creative expression of that so there's
never any male intent it's impossible
and so
your tool belt here
on the mountain is the different
resources
that you pick up because there are so
many of these different paths
and there's so many of these different
signposts on these paths and the
signposts are things like
the meditation retreats and the
aphorisms and the books
and the sages and all of these perennial
wisdoms and you
and you accumulate them into a beautiful
lattice work
and that lattice work is your tool belt
because the more of these faces the more
of these paths the more of the
signposts the larger and more robust
and beautiful and like uh
associative web of harmonics that you've
built up
if you know how to play several of the
notes in the octave instead of only one
or two notes in the octave you're going
to be able to
play a more harmonic melody
as the individual in the symphony
as in you have a higher possibility of
enlightenment a faster enlightenment
a more a process of
finding like we'll talk about in what
that aloo jude
that is such a style of finding
where the light bulb stays on
the satori stays on
and you get there fast
and that has a lot to do with this tool
belt it has a lot to do with the breadth
of the lattice work how many of the
different paths
have you studied how many of the
different signposts
have you analyzed because that same
style of
understanding applies directly to the
story of joseph and the code of many
colors
or the chameleon consciousness the
interviewer consciousness the synthesis
consciousness and when you get to that
level
your ability to navigate on a conceptual
lattice work as well as on an emotional
intelligence level
game over and especially if you have the
digital quotient in modernity with
mimetics
with knowing how to operate on the level
of running the channels across the
different social platforms
mwah game over
and that's why as alan watts said
we have these many paths but we have
this one end
and very similarly aldous huxley and
many others came to the same conclusion
they just went out and studied all of
the perennial wisdoms across the mystic
traditions
likewise i did as well and the
conclusion
is is that they are all different
faces they're different paths to the
same one
end to the same recognition of
the eternal awareness the eternal
consciousness that is being
colored by experience through all of the
different creation designs
and this is just one expression of that
and awareness and consciousness is the
god realization being aware
of awareness and then even that
in itself is dreamed even awareness or
consciousness is dreamed
by the absolute by the ineffable that is
our source
all right and you can see that
you have l0 there at the bottom the l0
is very much like the
ego so again in the flatness
there is no l0 to l10
and i'm exploring playing with the level
slash layers
as l7 at the top because of the
chakras and i think that's fascinating
to take that
crown chakra and have that be at the top
in the absolute so to have it be on a
scale from zero to seven instead of zero
to ten which i think is fascinating
and the l0 is very much like the ego
and the non-dual tradition would say
that you know the mountain portion
doesn't exist and yet the simultaneity
says that
the non-dual is the ultimate that this
doesn't exist and yet at the dualistic
concession level we'll say that
that person is suffering ultimately the
suffering doesn't happen
ultimately but here in this creation
design the person is suffering
and that's because they believe they're
a finite contracted egoic separate
entity
and that they want the eternal
imperturbable peace
and causeless joy by acknowledging and
recognizing the diamond necklace is
already around their neck and that they
are not going to find it by seeking
the temporal objects
that exist
outside
and so these layers
or levels they go up to the absolute
and you can think about them like the
chakras in a sense
that each one of the levels is slowly
rising you up more and more
like you can get to level one
in one of the paths and you can be in
level three in another one of the paths
and then you encounter somebody that's
at level
five in the path that you've never
explored
you've never heard of taoism where the
doubted shame in this person's already
at level five
on that path and what do they do when if
you have a high emotional intelligence
if you know how to ask them
questions what do you do you ask them
really good questions and they teach you
and they rise you up to like level two
on that path over a span of just a
couple conversations
and then you share with them what you've
learned about your
level 1 and level 3 on your paths and
that's how the dialectic works
to recognize the diamond necklace around
the neck that's what i've spent the last
couple years doing
and so at the top is the absolute the
ineffable the source the intuitive sense
of
infinity beyond experiencing and that
absolute enables the experiencer and the
experience
so the top of the mountain is the
recognition of the flatness of the paper
so you can be at level zero you can be
in an egoic state
if you told me five years ago that hey
there's nothing to seek
i would have no idea what you're talking
about hey this is just a dream
everything's just non-dual everything's
already perfect
it's just a bunch of energy modulating i
would have no idea what you're talking
about
and so this is the
multi-thousand-year discourse that's
been happening between the
sudden versus gradual awakening and
the reality is that it's simultaneous
it's both
i had a very gradual awakening over
several years leading up to my very
sudden satori on december 18th
and one of the series that we're
developing here
is around satori and sharing people's
satori with the world and making that
fun
to do and so we have many of these
projects lined up and if you want to
support us
you can join below
and so that's why it's important to
recognize when you look at the
neo advaita tradition that
a lot of the satsang movement
around the straight
communication of the absolute of the
ineffable
directly to level zero level one etc
is both very efficacious and it's also
skipping a lot and when you skip a lot
people don't get it a lot of the time
like the ego wants to take it and just
say that great it's all a dream nothing
matters and then it just goes off and
continues
self-dealing and continues being greedy
and seeking
conspicuous consumption and materialism
and fame and clout
and all that type of stuff that then
ends up hitting a breaking point anyway
and turning inward just like in the
parable of the prodigal son
and again this continues to point
over and over again to the true
simultaneity being the most paramount
thing here
because when you know how to
tailor like joseph in the code of many
colors
the conversation across all of the
layers
you can work with somebody at
the zero level and work with somebody at
the two level you can work with somebody
at the four
level maybe they're four on one path and
three on another path
and you understand that because you have
a very robust lattice work yourself
and then what happens is you're able to
tailor
the mirroring of the god consciousness
to them
so you through questions
can serve as a mirror of the god
realized
state and then that person
that's why the non-dual neo-advaita
direct
path is sometimes
a panacea and there's
more tailoring that can happen where we
can say things like
suffering is acting as a drill sergeant
for your awakening
to somebody that's maybe at level zero
whereas in the neo advaita tradition
they would say something along the lines
of suffering doesn't exist this is all
just a dream
and that person would be like ah and
you can see where i'm going with this
five years ago hearing suffering as a
drill sergeant for awakening makes a lot
more sense
than five years ago hearing that
suffering is a complete
dream this is all a dream it doesn't
exist
and so that's the ability so
simultaneity with joseph and the code of
many colors with being able to navigate
all of these layers like a ninja
to mirror in the god realized state in a
way that can
fluidly navigate all of these layers
from the ego to the absolute from the
non-dual
to the dualistic rhythmic balanced
interchange
and also to the dualistic
seeking and finding an enlightenment
and also to the multiplicity in the
individuality
and the meanings of the unique artistic
expression at the level of the iris
so the paths are the roads to the
diamond necklace
that is already around your neck as
again adi shankara said i am right now
in my village but i need a road to reach
my village
the signposts are like the tool belt the
books the meditation retreats the
aphorisms and the sages
and skillful spirituality is like joseph
and the code of many colors
is knowing how to tailor to each layer
not doing just one panacea-style
teaching for all
and again that's really visible here
you look at all of the different paths
all of those different sign
posts on those paths
you can see that there's only five paths
illustrated here and they're kind of
some are more straight some are a little
bit twisty and turny
but ultimately there are infinite paths
and that's why people like judeo
krishnamurti
said that there is no path and there is
no leader
and that eternally there's just going to
be
billions and trillions of
these findings that happen
it's the gps callback mechanism
it's that parable of the prodigal son
turning back inward
and there's all these unique styles of
finding
so there's not a single panacea a path
or signposts there's ones that are more
efficacious
and that's why the aphorisms like i
and my father are one and that's vamasi
are so profound because they're shortest
and they're synthetic across the
different cultures
they're very clearly pointing to the
same thing
and there are other aphorisms and there
are other sages
that have had a lot more controversy
and so when you take things like ramana
maharshi just saying something simple
like god is the seer
or saint francis of assisi saying that
that which you seek
is what is seeking so your own
seeking is what you're seeking
you are it the seer is it
the seeker is it that's the diamond
necklace already around your neck
and again the tailoring component to it
is the most critical it's the true
simultaneity it's the ability to
tailor to exactly the level that people
are
at to exactly their lattice work
of the different paths and signposts
and this is also where the profound
concepts of the sufi metaphysics like
what that aloo jude
comes in the unity of all finding
which was in fact the main catalytic
agent of my satori on december 18th was
finally understanding that word
thanks to william chitik and his piece
on the ibn rabi society's page
where wadata ujud for me for
a year or more meant the unity of all
being in existence
until i read his piece and it actually
meant the unity of all finding
in its more nuanced detail which means
that there are 8 billion
unique styles of union with the absolute
just here in this creation design there
are 8 billion unique ways
for the gps callback
functionality of the absolute to work
so maya the illusion that's very
intoxicating
works as an agent of the absolute
to veil itself to forget
and it goes out seeking externally and
then it hits the
egoic breaking point and it turns back
inward and this is a unique process of
going outward a unique process of coming
back inward and discovering the
perennial wisdoms discovering the god
realization
each satori is unique and that's the
point
is that satori is happening
at that speed across the infinite
and that's the most unique thing is that
what i experienced on december 18th
of 2020 is happening at that speed
across the infinite and that's why
this is the coolest game in town
and that's why the veiling mechanism is
the coolest
feature in town we can veil
ourselves from ourselves
and have no idea what the nature of our
reality is
it's the most beautiful thing
we forget our own nature and then we
remember
our own nature and when we remember our
artistic expression
externally becomes more like a divine
clear channel
of the absolute highest morality
and what then both means the god
realization so recognizing the pupil
going inward as well as the god
actualization
the going outward the creative artistic
contribution
the iris
but again that can be perverted with
that egoic breaking point we talked
about
versus the awakened awareness that
creatively expresses
so once you go in it's woo way
effortless action going out
and that's the source light that
refracts through
each of our unique diamonds in the net
so there's injuries net the net of being
and it has
each one of the nodes
is stitched together in the net
right here is a node in the net
and that little node has the jewel it
has the diamond and it's unique
for this unit and it's unique for your
unit that's the unique individuality the
unique multiplicity
and so the source light refracts
uniquely through each of our diamonds as
the artistic expression
and each dreamed diamond lattice work
that we have can be visualized with the
ai coach
dashboard and that's something we talked
about in chapter six of high level
perception in detail
where we can actually take and visualize
our lattice work we can visualize our
psychometrics our biometrics
we can retain youthful homeostatic
capacity youthful rejuvenation feel like
an 18 year old
for decades if not centuries and
creatively contribute and express
both externally throughout the cosmos as
well as internally as we go inward
into the transcension hypothesis of all
of the metaverse technologies that are
emerging of the
artificial general intelligence the
indistinguishable virtual realities
the neural link that type of stuff
and that's why that lattice work with
the ai coach is really critical because
it assists
both in the god realization and the god
actualization process is fascinating
so literally it assists with
the unity of all finding i love it
and then the gondola
so you have the gondola over here you
can see that
over there on the right the gondola
is the shortcut
it's the rare candy it's the level up
faster
and you can think about that like
entheogens so you can take
a heroic dose of psilocybin or
maybe 150 micrograms of lsd
or maybe
a little bit of 5mu dmt
and what'll happen
is that your
understanding of the nature of reality
will skyrocket
but what happens is that it skyrockets
like the gondola
but then once you see the absolute
you go right back down but you don't go
all the way back down to level zero you
might go to level one
layer one but you can't just get off of
the gondola
at the absolute from taking an entheogen
in a sense the entheogens they slowly
expose you more and more to the absolute
they expose you more and more to
becoming aware of awareness itself
and so entheogens are one another one is
the direct path teachings
rupert spyra has been a big influence on
me there so has been tino masaro
and the direct path teachings are
fantastic the neo advaita tradition has
been fascinating as well with tony
parsons and jim newman fred davis
it's been really interesting studying
and learning from them as well
and interviewing them because
they are very much like the gondola it's
very much like
when you get the dream analogy just like
when you go to bed
and you sleep for a third of your life
and you simulate out
these dreams where you immerse yourself
as a first person
observer in the dream you're by the
eiffel tower
in paris and you're experiencing the
environment and
then before you know it boom you're
in tokyo and now you're in tokyo and
you're experiencing that environment so
the observer stayed the same
but the dreamed landscapes changed
and that's the same thing as this the
observer the awareness is eternal and
stays the same
and it gets colored by experience
in all of the different dreamed reality
designs and this is just
one of them
even right now it just feels
so beautiful just even speaking about it
to be aware of that is
so ineffable
and it's home it's home
so what better to do than to communicate
home
with these funny vocal vibrations and
symbols and artistic
distillations
and this profound moment is happening at
exactly
1 11 a.m
pacific time
hmm
we can get better
at making it so that the gondola
ends up bringing us
closer and closer to the absolute faster
the entheogens the direct path teachings
the neo-divided teachings
and that's why a lot of the
psychotherapeutic
movement around anthogens has a lot to
do with
the before and after experience of
integration
because when you just go and trip jump
and you never integrate
you're actually barely
ascending whereas when you actually
integrate
you ascend a lot fast and especially if
you can
hit the tennis ball back with people
that are very god realized that can act
as a mirror
of the ineffable for you
and that's very much what a lot of the
neoadvice appointings
are trying to do
which is be the
the god realized mirror of the ineffable
four people
yet the tailoring of it
and also the jumping directly
to the
all is a dream and nobody is here doing
anything it's just all an appearance of
modulations of energy
is a little bit
jumping and there's a step
there's like a two-step process that we
were reflecting on
with bentino's recent teachings
where rather than taking that just
single step where you take the two-step
is where you recognize that you are not
the egoic
contracted separate entity that is
finite
but you recognize the pupil you
recognize the god realization
become aware of awareness itself and
then
from there once you've stabilized that i
am-ness
recognition then you can jump
to the absolute to the ineffable where
you recognize
even that awareness is dreamed
it is an agent of the infinite of the
absolute
and so the crevices are
where you fall into non-middle slash
tantric path
sahaja samadhi so where you look here
you see the crevices they're closer to
the top
and what happens at those crevices
similar to when you're
hiking mount everest and you've seen
all of the insane content where people
are
hiking up to the top of everest and
there are these
insane fresh snowfalls that happen in
these crazy
crevices where people just drop like 50
feet to their death
because it's just fresh powder and they
didn't see it and boom
it's nuts and so
the crevices are very much like
when people
don't do the middle path when they don't
do
the tantric weave when they don't do
sahaja samadhi meaning that
if you're not weaving your profound
enlightened realizations into the social
fabric
in your daily activities then you're
missing the point
if you want to if it's your unique
expression of infinity
to be [ __ ] off
in the mountaintop alone with your
enlightenment then by all means that's
your expression of infinity
and if you're stuck in the egoic state
and you have absolutely no interest
whatsoever in enlightenment and you want
to continue chasing
rolexes and yachts and private jets
and louis vuitton and chanel and all of
that
then keep going keep going until you hit
your breaking point it's your own unique
expression of infinity
and so that's why the middle path the
middleway sahaja samadhi the tantric
path the goldilocks zone
just like planet earth again great
analogies
is where you take your profound
enlightened realizations and you weave
them into the actual social fabric with
your daily activities
and that's why the combination of an
enlightened
entrepreneur is the best in my opinion
the enlightened entrepreneur is like the
enlightened
artist and especially the enlightened
engineer so when you really synthesize
the enlightened entrepreneur
engineer artist scientist
out into the world after the god
realization it's game over
that those are the future builders
those are the people that are going to
be the leaders of the future
those are the ones that are going to
vortex up everybody
else to the top of the mountain
to help meet the basic needs of
everybody else on the planet
those are the people the enlightened
entrepreneurs artists
engineers scientists
those are the people the ones that have
went
all the way inward to god realization
and now effortlessly express themselves
artistically outward
to maximize planetary prosperity and
abundance and flourishing
so to avoid falling into those crevices
is critical
and then we use the term homeomorphisms
to explain
the analogies that also relate to the
flat mountain
so homeomorphism simply mean topological
isomorphisms
meaning that the way that the mountain
is compared to the ocean and to the well
into the iceberg
are the same mathematically speaking
that they're
similar and that's why in this case
you have the ocean slash well
analogy which will show right now
where people say you have to dig all the
way to water
so you have the simultaneity of the
multiplicity
the individuation
and that's where a vast majority of
people are at
and then you go one layer down in the
well
and you reach a little bit of water and
that's
oneness that's when you recognize the
oneness
and that's you hit a little bit of water
and use a lot of people stop
there but you don't stop there you keep
digging
you dig all the way until you pierce the
veil until you hit
the abundant water at the bottom of the
well until you literally hit the ocean
that is the self that is self
realization that is god realization
that's when you understand non-dual
awareness
that's when you actually get it because
oneness can be from a perspective of
physicalism
which is where i was at in especially
like the fall of 2020
in a perspective of oneness physicalism
is a really good way to put it
but to shatter through that and
experience satori where you recognize
that the awareness and the consciousness
is it is itself it it is eternal
it is shared it is what is
experiencing these infinite creation
designs we
are that that's the profound shift
and so this is a homeomorphism which is
the
well analogy and also the ocean analogy
where you talk about the drop the drop
becomes the ocean
is the first one the ego dissolves into
the oceanicness
and then and that's only if the ego
forms if the bubble forms in the first
place there are plenty of people around
the planet that
do conscious parenting for their infants
especially indigenous
where they never form the egoic bubble
they have
only the truth
of infinity and eternity and their
individuated expression from birth
they get that from birth which is
fascinating that's the way that
conscious parenting will be moving
forward and especially given the things
that we architect like the vr pedagogy
and whatnot as we continue getting the
financial support to succeed on all of
those projects out here
and so in the oceanic analogy if you do
have the contracted egoic entity that is
the bubbled ego
it dissolves into the oceanicness first
and that's the first step is that
instead of that's the two step instead
of the one step that leaps the two step
is the first one
is what we just described the drop
becomes the ocean
and the ocean recognizes the waves of
experience
so you recognize i am the ocean
experiencing the waves just like i am
the sky experiencing the clouds
so you're not caught up in the wave or
caught up in the cloud
as an egoic finite separate entity
and so so that's the first step and then
the second step after that
is to recognize that even the ocean
the witness the observer the awareness
itself and the experiences of the waves
all of that is dreamed
and that's when you pull out that last
thorn of even the witness the observer
awareness itself
and you recognize the infinite you
recognize the absolute you recognize
the ineffable the ultimate
and one more
homeomorphism is the iceberg
and this is in high level perception
where you have in the
most surface level part of the iceberg
you have the relationship of the person
with the objects and they're focused on
just the objects
and then around the surface level they
begin aware
they become more aware they become more
conscious of their relationship with the
object
just like the social dilemma helped
people become conscious of their
relationship with their smartphone
and then one layer lower in the iceberg
is when the subject becomes aware of
other subjects
so that's when you do the long
games of just looking into other
people's eyes these exercises
where you stay silent and you don't
laugh and you don't move and you just
look at their eyes and you recognize
god is in their pupils just like god is
in your pupils and you recognize that
and then the very last step in the
iceberg and this is at the very deepest
depths
of that's why it requires that submarine
to get down there's a lot of water
pressure it's pretty intense to be able
to pierce the veil
at that level the veilless veil the
gateless gate
a lot of people stop for a reason they
are addicted to their layers of egoic
identity and so in the very last case
what you do is you
turn awareness on itself you turn
attention
on awareness itself your own
awareness you turn your own attention on
your own awareness
and at that point it's game over because
you get it you got it
you found out that god is the seer you
got it
and that's why it's topologically
isomorphic that's why these are
homeomorphisms because
the iceberg and the well slash ocean and
the mountain
flat mountain they are all very
mathematically
morphisms onto one another
topologically and also structurally
and
that's it flat mountain is going to be
in high level perception
in the final hard soft cover
i'm so grateful that we had the satori
happen right before the christmas
publication date
because it made me patient in
getting excited about the adding
of the satori moment into high level
perception but you can also find
riffs on the ineffable which we just
published on
amazon as a kindle as well as a
paperback
which is exciting it's super short it's
just like
20 or 30 pages or something and just a
couple sentences
in each chapter it's really really short
and really profound and to the point and
explain like i'm five
to ten short chapters and we made a
whole video on it as well
which you can find on our channel and so
we're gonna get used to that sort of
kindle direct publishing
as well to get these pieces of content
out so people can actually get the
paperbacks and the digital versions of
them
so you'll see that more and more i'm
really excited
that flat mountain is now out and also
fully explained by me in this content
and again concepts like what the unity
of all finding both god realization and
god actualization
again really building up the lattice
work of all of the different
paths and signposts turning yourself
into joseph and the code of many colors
and being able to fluidly
like a jedi navigate all of the
different
layers of the non-dual the dualistic
concession
and the individuality the multiplicity
again many paths one end
and the
very simple way of just understanding
you know just
on the non-dual it's just tatavamasi
you're already that i'm already that
we're already that
and on the mountain on the duelist the
concession it's just like the parable of
the prodigal son it's just like the turn
inward it's just like finding the
diamond necklace recognizing the diamond
necklace already around your neck
and that true simultaneity around
the navigation like a jedi
of these layers and recognizing that at
the end of the day
that it's all a beautiful appearance
a dreamed appearance a fluctuation
modulation of energy just like of music
it's lila it's the divine play it's the
cosmic play and it's gorgeous and it's
eternal
and it's going to keep happening
and so if you're in a state where you're
recognizing that suffering is definitely
the drill sergeant of awakening then
recognize where you're at if you're at
l0 or l1 right now and you
want to understand this diamond necklace
you want to turn inward on your
awareness itself as the first step
then dedicate yourself full time to
truth
because you gain compound interest
the more you dedicate yourself full time
to truth you get it faster
you seek and find and become enlightened
faster
and then you weave your realizations
into the social fabric faster you become
more peaceful more happy faster
and then your family friends co-workers
and civilization becomes happier
and more peaceful faster so dedicate
yourself full time to it it's the truest
thing about you is that seeking impulse
i love you very much thanks for tuning
in to this
direct communication about the
beautiful flat mountain
which i adore so much one of my favorite
visuals
to date and we're going to continue
making these artistic distillations even
more
and more simple and profound and
also into a big digital sistine chapel
style
visualization especially of these
homeomorphisms
and michelangelo is a massive
inspiration definitely
one of the goats greatest of all times
and if this video brought you value
please
like the video please subscribe if you
haven't and please
share it with other people that would be
awesome
and it'll be insightful for them
especially the ones that this will
really resonate with
because the true simultaneity is really
hard to come about
and that's why it's called flat mountain
people are like what the [ __ ] is flat
mountain mountains can't be flat
you know if that's the first reaction
from somebody mountains can't be flat
then that's a binary style thinking
that's a inability to see the true
simultaneity inability to hold
two contrary perspectives at the same
time
and that's what we have we have a bunch
of people that think that it's just
non-duality we have a bunch of people
that think that it's just
duality we have a bunch of people that
think that it's just individuality
but it's really all of them it's all of
them at the same time the ultimate is
the non-dual
but it's expressing itself as the dual
and as the multiplicity and we have to
wake ourselves up to that and respect
that
to both god realize and god actualize
again it's just the pupil and it's the
iris it's that simple it's really
childlike
alright and let me know how you feel in
the comments below i'd love to hear from
you
where you're at and how this resonated
with you
and if you'd like to support us do join
you can join
the community as well every member that
joins we give them exclusive perks and
benefits which is exciting
and then we also fuel their
contributions directly into
all of our projects
that's all i adore you so much thank you
infinite love and super pumped
to continue these visual
distillations and synthesis on the
as close as we can to the ineffable it's
so fun
it's unbelievably fun
be humble enough to know that you can
never
actually distill artistically what the
ineffable is
but be hungry enough
and excited enough and playful enough
and artistic enough to
get as close as you possibly can
to creating maps of the territory
that's what this expression of infinity
is up to
adore you thank you
you